well it's going to be brady singer again
his second straight start will come
against the indians he's coming off a
start against cleveland it was game one
of the doubleheader he had a complete
game he went seven innings gave up six
hits a couple of runs
line drive right field fair ball down
into the corner it goes cut off nicely
by isbell and that'll keep mile straw to
a lead-off double that's his 28th double
of the year and he's now
10 for his last 19 at the point well
ahmed rosario
ball four wasn't even close
jose ramirez going to left field
he won't get straw home he had to make
sure that ben and tendee wouldn't charge
in and make that line drive catch so the
bases are loaded with nobody else nobody
out bases loaded and the batter is fran
mill reyes singer's pitch and it's swung
on drill to right center that's the base
hit straw scores rosario scores ramirez
is motoring to third as the throw goes
toward third and it's a two run single
by fran mill reyes to right center and
the indians have jumped all over brady
singer
and lead this ball game by a score of
two to nothing now harold ramirez they
want to go away and they'll get two
indians get another run home it's three
to nothing but now the bases are empty
with two down
two balls two strikes
now the unsettling
sight of
mike matheny
with trainer nick kenny going to the
mound to check on the well-being of
brady singer mike matheny and royal's
trainer said you know what brady that's
enough so it'll be urban santana with
the count two balls two strikes two outs
nobody on
and that's hit well to center field but
taylor is back
so
santana ends the inning by getting
zimmer on a fly ball to center
royals will get a second look at aaron
cevalle who missed
almost three months of the season this
year with a sprained finger on his right
hand which was really unfortunate
savalay cuts it off and flips it over to
chang for the out
right to rosario at short
[Applause]
two down salvi's playing in his 156th
game
and he will take high for a two-out walk
two down in the royals first with a
runner on here is andrew benintendi what
a year he's had
hits one deep into the right field
corner gone
so give him 26
and 27 rbis this month and the royals
answer with two and the bottom of the
first kendricks morales is somewhere
watching with a big smile on his face in
a big cuban cigar what a beautiful high
fastball there he just turned on it that
ball's elevated already that's why
hitters like elevation as it's already
up there all they got to do is put a
good swing on it and that's not always
easy to do
strike three called got him looking at a
fastball to end the inning albert
rosario walked in the first inning a
little hesitation by santana and that
worked rosario strikes out and that's
irving's second and now jose ramirez
tonight he is two for two that's one
double second double for his
first double of the night rather his
31st
double on the year it's the second
double for the team
and a runner in scoring position with
one out so the indians have two on with
one out and harold ramirez coming up
high popped right field bad at himself
he had a good pitch to hit and he stayed
on it that way
jose ramirez goes to third but now there
are two downs the 1-2 pitch and bradley
swings and misses and santana works his
way out of trouble in the third inning
urban santana had to come on with two
outs in the first inning after brady
singer came out with an injury
he's pitched
two and a third scoreless
chang hits one to right center and
isbell makes the play the ball had slice
on it he almost overran it
and now perez is on with a one-out walk
there's a ground ball in the hole how do
you like that second game in a row we've
seen jimenez go the other way he beats
the shift easy base hit right there and
he's two for two
here's the 0-1
bounced in there gets past perez back to
the screen
both base runners will move up on the
wild pitch
perez to third jimenez to second
on the ground two hops to lopez the
runner at third was roberto perez that's
not the best candidate for the contact
play and mike figures it's time for a
fresh arm so urban santana comes on
unexpected in the first inning and he
gets the game to the fourth and here's
coleman with runners at second and third
and two down
line to left ben attendee is right there
cleveland leaves two coleman quiets the
storm salvi walked his first time up
off the end of the bat
and down
and salvi's digging for second mile
straw's throw is offline enough for a
lead-off double every first pitch that
that last inning
that civalli threw was a curveball a
split finger or slider and salvi caught
a slider
the yo-1 pitch a swing and a high fly
ball deep to right zimmer's going back
salvi's gonna tag zimmer with the catch
here's the throw it is cut off and perez
goes second to third now a fly ball
could tie this ball game now carlos
santana is up
and that'll get the job done
[Applause]
zimmer's going to try to get behind it
but this is a long heave from right and
that'll go
right into cleveland's dugout
as salvage scores the tying run
santana's had very few big moments at
the plate against his former team when
he gets a sac fly and it's 3-3 in the
fourth 3-3 bottom of the six
jimenez gets nikki lopez one down
nicki's 0 for three
here comes salvador perez
there it is
into the corner
gone
47. man salvador perez
just jolted that that ball was just
tattered and battered
and not coming back what a beautiful
shot that was split finger talked about
him how he's been putting it down below
the knees all night not there boy he
jumped on that and it was a no doubter
oh look at this step
fans want a curtain call here
home run number 47 for salvador perez
one shy of the team record the royals
lead cleveland 4-3
and the new pitcher is jake brents he
will face a pinch hitter in oscar
mercado
and a line drive bases in a right field
for mercado that is his third
pinch hit in aided bats
man you chang oh for three on the night
and he lines one up the alley in right
center field mercado on his way to third
taylor turns and throws to the cutoff
man here comes mercado home from the
plate hit the mound they catch a break
and they've tied the game at four
you chang
with a ringing double up the right
center field alley
and mercado with the hammer down came
all the way around to score blake parker
stays on for the eighth in a 4-4 tie
fooled by the pitch isbell tried to save
his swing but could not
whit hits a base hit into left field
so he got a fastball and he was ready
for it
and he's on with one out one on one out
tied at four in the bottom of the eighth
he is running and now he stops and lopez
hits it to the gap
merrifield is around third he will score
nikki's on his way to third with a go
ahead triple
vicky lopez
going from 0-2 down
to 3-2 and he earned it slider cutter
just stayed up and harold ramirez was
playing nikki lopez on the left field
line i mean it's wide open there
wit saw it all the way
but great touch and tightly hit
takes the pressure off salvi out on the
deuce something here but lopez timely
hit
whoa
salvi went but the royals are going to
get a run anyway
was ruled a swing by
first base umpire lance barksdale but it
got through perez
and the royals lead 6-4 josh stalmont
going to try and close this one out
stomach makes a nice play that could
have been ugly because hanser alberto
was right behind stamon he could have
made the play but thankfully that's
stuck in staman's glove
deep center field
and taylor has room
[Applause]
and that'll be bounce to the right side
hands are alberto throws to first and
the royals
beat cleveland tonight 6-4
coming from behind twice
salvador perez hits his 47th home run of
the year